foreign
he's not violent in any way just his
tone and he's just you know he's a big
guy and when he screams it makes you
nervous you know
I want to reframe that that's violence
and men are can be especially men can be
very tactful in their use of violence
[Music]
what up what up this is John with the Dr
John deloney show
so grateful that you've joined us
talking about mental health marriages
emotional health parenting whatever's
going on in your world I'm here for it
been doing this for 20 years sitting
with people who are the wheels are fun
more than 20 years now good grief I'm
getting old man the wheels have fallen
off
and it's just something is so annoying
something is so frustrating or something
is dire and man this culture we built
for ourselves we are lonely lonely
lonely and I'm always honored when
people reach out and say hey can you
help and I mean I have the right answer
man but I promise I'll sit with you and
listen and we'll figure it out together
if you want to be on the show go to John
deloney.com ask ask ask and fill out the
form or go to uh give me a buzz at
1-844-693-3291 if you were younger than
35 I don't know if you know that you can
actually
um punch numbers into that little box
that you carry around with you and talk
to other people which is rad
um but nobody's gonna answer the phone
if you call you can just leave a message
and uh then somebody will call you back
it's pretty pretty cool this uh phone
technology
um we're getting to the end of the
pre-sale season if you have thought like
I think I'm going to pre-order this book
please today's the day make it happen go
to John deloney.com pre-order building a
non-anxious life it's breaking all kinds
of pre-order records in this building
it's I'm excited to have it out
um and the stores that are reading it
and picking it up it's just kind of it's
developed a momentum of its own which is
is just it's super exciting
um and if you order it before it comes
out it comes with the free audio book if
you're an audiobook person
um we're autographing some of them and I
don't know how that goes but that'll be
on the website and it also comes with
the digital copy and a couple other
things so please go check it out go to
John deloney.com and grab your copy
let's go out to Orlando Florida and talk
to Dear Marie
what's up Marie hi there hi there what's
up thanks for having me Dr John of
course thank you for calling what's
happening
so I've been married I've been with my
husband for 30 years married 28.
um we're you know we're younger you know
50s we had our kids early they're out of
the house
um but the question is so he has anxiety
he takes
um like anxiety medication but for the
most part he just snaps off like he just
yells and gets you know me or whatever
the situation is he gets frustrated
easily
um it's been going on our entire
marriage I've just learned to push it
under the rug and figure it wasn't me it
wasn't about me and you know that he
just has anxiety issues well it's
starting to get you know it's getting to
me again and you know and I just don't
know kind of the direction we should go
we've had talks about it
um he understands
he knows his anger issues he's not
violent in any way just his tone and
he's just you know he's a big guy and
when he screams it makes you nervous you
know
I want to reframe that that's violence
and men are can be especially men women
too but especially men can be very
tactful in their use of violence what I
mean by that is they can shut your
nervous system down they can make your
whole body feel unsafe to be in your
home as though they punched you in the
face and they never lay a finger on you
and that's part of the Insidious nature
of it when he if he's screaming and
yelling he's a big guy and he's
hollering and throwing stuff and getting
mad at you for whatever
um yeah that's every bit violence that
is every bit violence
and no he's not he's not where he
doesn't throw things or nothing like
that or he's not like physically violent
but yeah the tone and the screaming and
he's just aggravated at traffic at
people at me you know just like and it
goes in waves you know some days he's
just a you know months he's the nicest
person in the world he'll do anything
for you why is he why he's aggravated
it's hard because he's on the phone but
you said you all have talked about this
why does he choose to live in misery
like this
he I
mean but why has that not been a
lifelong I'm gonna I'm gonna go down the
rabbit hole and figure this out because
I love this woman so much that she
doesn't deserve this
right and by the way I love myself so
much I don't want to have a stroke right
I don't want to die young
right yeah I mean verbally he says he
knows he has a problem he has anger
issues he so he tries to medicate it you
know and like with the Zoloft or he's on
something different now and his whole
house almost gave him no personality and
then when he's on now it's not enough
and I I think he needs some kind of
therapy he needs to maybe cognitive
therapy or he I'll tell you right now he
needs one thousand percent needs therapy
he needs to go see somebody
one million percent you can't make him
do that though
he verbally told me he would yeah
but he still hasn't made an appointment
He's not going to he's not going to he
hasn't he blames that he can't get
through to anyone yeah that's nonsense
he is chosen not to in fact I'll call
his bluff I'm gonna give you three
months of free better help but at the
end of this call
it's I'll give you a code for free
therapy that's they will call you back
and he will be in contact with a
therapist within 24 hours
oh wow and he can do it from his
computer he won't do it but I'm just
telling you I'll call that bluff
okay wow but he's not on the phone
the bigger thing is you
so I want I want to separate a few
things for you number one if you've ever
listened to this show I say this all the
time behavior is a language
I rarely care what people say
I want to know what they do
so he can say I know and I shouldn't be
doing this and I'm really working on it
you're not
he's not right he's he's absolutely not
because his leg his behavior is telling
you everything he needs to know that he
would rather sit in his anger and misery
than have a marriage worth living for
he would rather feel empowered and
encapsulated in a safe little bubble
behind this anger and rage then be
exposed and vulnerable which is the only
path towards true intimacy and
connection
right that's the choice he's making so
yeah cool you though can only control
you
and so for the millions and millions of
millions of people out there who are
roommates with their husband or wife
who are just wondering every day what is
it about me why why does he not like me
why does she not like me so so deeply
you have to ask yourself those questions
what is the language that your behavior
is communicating so I'll ask you have
you been to see somebody
now it's time because you're living an
abusive marriage
have you have a group of women that you
reach out to and just and you plug in
with once a week once every two weeks
yeah I have a good Core group of friends
okay what do they say about it
well most of them are divorced
they're like yeah that's just the way
this is
they're like they say the same thing
that I'm an abusive marriage you know
and I know this thing is mental abuse
physical abuse he's never cursed at me
he told me I was awful or a loser or
anything like that doesn't matter no
he's never used that kind of language
right you're making excuses for it
yeah I know I am you don't need him he
doesn't need you to protect him he's
doing a great job protecting himself
right
I think in protecting him you're
actually protecting yourself because if
you actually felt
if you actually truly sat in how
freaking lonely you are
I better take your breath away
is that fair
yep
yeah
I'm so sorry no don't be sorry I'm
heartbroken for you
yeah it's hard because I do love them
you know we are you know we're
physically attracted to each other and I
make those excuses for that and I'm like
well the time that he's good he's great
and then when he goes down that rabbit
hole like you say you know I'm like oh
there he is there's a little you know
demon showing himself and what you don't
realize maybe you realize that that's
not fair maybe you do most people don't
realize is that your body sets off to
protect you
even during the good times
so even the good times you're not fully
plugged into each other because there's
still a part of your body that would be
failing you if it wasn't on guard
it's true
and so it's like hugging somebody with
one arm
you can hug them tight but it's not all
the way
right and so I think the conversation
has to
eventually do one of two things Step One
is
um and I I don't think this is the path
but I'm never gonna take this option
from somebody
um in a violent one I'll make phone
calls in this situation I can tell you
just as your friend
I mean this is what you've made peace
with this is what you've made peace with
and if he just starts yelling and you
choose to leave and go sleep in hotel
until he quits being acting like a
four-year-old
um then cool I hope that's not what you
cash out and choose to live
the other the other piece is
you sitting down somewhere in a neutral
location not in your home
but somewhere
where you look across a table and you've
probably written this down in a form of
a letter so that you can read it and
because it's gonna be emotional it's
gonna be heavy and you look at him and
say I'm so lonely I can't breathe and
you scare me and you've scared me for 30
years
and I'm scared of my own home and it has
to end now
no more excuses either you have the
courage to leave me husband
or you have the courage to go get well
but I can't be scared and terrified in
my own home anymore by the man that I
love more than anybody else
yeah that's it
that's perfect but hold on it's perfect
but it's scary because he might say I'm
not going to counseling it's not
you know who you married it's been this
way for 20 years whatever crap he wants
to throw
and then you have to make a hard call
the or what decision or what you're
gonna go well I tried it's cool
yeah are you going to move in with one
of your divorce friends for 30 days
I mean you're gonna have to have that
conversation
right what was what would be the next
decision or step that's up that's up to
you yeah yeah exactly that's what I mean
I'd have to come to
come to Jesus with that you know I Think
Jesus has come to you
I think the re what happened that that
that inspired this call usually
something happened
um
a friends of ours we were on a trip and
some French friends finally saw the real
Nick
and I saw and I was humiliated you know
the way he talked to them he exploited
on them because they were talking about
how he's driving and just ridiculous
stuff we couldn't make a decision on a
restaurant he just
yelled at everyone
and I just sat there and like total
embarrassment sure and that you know and
it was just like the final oh my God
someone else finally saw this
he apologized later he was he he
apologized for embarrassing me but I
don't think he was embarrassed he didn't
say he was he just he was sorry that he
embarrassed me and then he felt terrible
for that and that he would do therapy he
said he would but that was two weeks ago
you know and I haven't brought it up
just letting him
figure out but that's always been your
move and he doesn't figure it out and he
won't figure it out you're right it
never will
yeah
yeah and so
you you choosing to be neutral
right on a in a burning house you you go
down in flames
yeah and it's interesting you said that
because in neutral because in my
business life I'm in total control of
course you are but in my personal life
I've I've like let that I'm like uh this
is abuse don't deal with it it's what it
does to us
what it does
the number of people I've met with over
the years that are bulldogs
in their professional life
and just get beat up one side up down
the other at home it's super common
because here's why
at work we feel very confident in what
we do especially as we move up the
ladder and as our business grows or our
profession our professional status grows
we feel we feel
um competent we feel confident because
we have a series of little wins
underneath us that we that we stand upon
I know I can do this
at home
we are haunted by that terrifying scary
little question
do you love me
and that is a whole different skill set
that's a different part of your brain
that's a different everything and you
are terrified of the answer of that
question because you get the answer
every day y'all just don't want to own
it and the answer is he would rather
act like a child act like a baby scream
yell kick shake his baby rattle then he
would provide a safe warm home for his
wife
yeah and after 30 years I can't imagine
that level of pain
yeah
it's exhausting frustrating
I have a picture of like a dog house in
my head
and he's inside it just breathing really
heavy in there kind of half asleep
and you're chained to a little stake
outside that dog house
and you don't have to go in there but
you can't you're not letting yourself go
anywhere else
oh yeah and you've made peace out there
you're really kind when the neighbors
walk by to Pat you on the head
and you curl up sometimes a neighbor's
kid will come play with toys and really
good and you're good at sitting and
doing all the rules at work
but that breathing
that that's that growl is still there
right behind you inside that dark
doghouse
in the crazy part is is that uh chain is
not even hooked up
right it's not a mental change it is
so for whatever it's worth hear me say
this you are worth more than the life
you're living right now
he is too
and if he wants to call my show I would
love to talk to him
but he's not here so I can only talk to
you you have to go call a counselor and
saying I'm gonna go talk to somebody
you have to write down in the form of a
letter what you actually feel
I am sick and tired of being scared in
my own home
haunted and terrified by the man who I
love so much
I'm tired of you scaring our friends
I'm tired that our kids don't want to be
in this house because they don't know
what version of you they're going to get
and most importantly I'm tired of
watching the man I love kill himself
slowly
in the nerd world we call it long tail
suicide a slow angry raged out
distracted suicide
but non-engagement can't be an option
anymore unless that's just the way
You're Gonna Roll dude I hope I hope you
look in the mirror and realize that
Marie from Orlando is worth more than
that I can't give that to you
hang on the line we're gonna hook you up
with better help and When Calls Bluff
and I'm going to send you a copy of
building a non-anxious life I'm also
going to send you a copy own your past
change your future I think that's a book
that you would get some great benefit
about living in traumatic situations and
these stories that keep us Chained and
then asking that scary question what are
we going to do next
um so I'm going to send you both up I'm
gonna hook you up anything you need call
me back I'll walk with you
but this is going to take a drastic snow
globe shake-up for anything new to
happen in this marriage and I think
that's going to be up to you we'll be
right back
this episode is sponsored by betterhelp
hey this is deloni I hope you all are
doing well listen sometimes it's hard to
get our brains to turn off and I know
what I'm talking about I am the king of
racing thoughts they've kept me up at
night they've got me up early and kept
me from connecting with people I love if
you find your thoughts start to race
right before bed or during other super
inconvenient times a great way to make
those racing thoughts slow down or stop
is to talk them through and therapy gave
me a place to do that so I could get off
the negative thought treadmill learn
positive coping skills set healthy
boundaries and find some mental and
emotional peace and it can help you too
if you're thinking of starting therapy
give better help a try better help is
convenient because it's entirely online
so it's flexible and can fit into your
schedule just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist and you can even
switch therapists at any time for no
extra charge so take a break from racing
thoughts with better help visit
betterhelp.com baloney today to get 10
off your first month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash deloni
all right let's go out to Denver
Colorado and talk to Joe what's up Joe
hey Dr Delaney first time uh caller I'm
glad to and honored to talk to you today
dude I'm honored that you called man
what's up
so um my question is and I can explain
the back story am I crazy for thinking
that my wife can use her anxiety
disorder as a weapon against me
as somebody who was once diagnosed with
an anxiety disorder no they make
extraordinary weapons oh like give me
give me your give me your uh your
backstory
okay so I've been married a little over
a year
and um
I didn't know about my wife's
um
anxiety disorder the first time we were
together we were together about a year
and a half
we split up and then covet happened and
we got back together a year later we got
engaged a year later we got married and
here we are
um
I didn't know about my wife's anxiety
disorder the first time we went out and
um
before she was with me
um she was with a person who was very
verbally abusive that brought out her
anxiety as from her childhood that got
worse and worse
um
ever since we got engaged into married
it comes out a little more and more the
longer that we're together
um and it it shows in weird ways
um right now my major issue that I have
is uh my my wife spends a lot of money
on mobile applications on her phone that
she says helps her anxiety
absolutely bull crap on a stick makes it
10 times worse 100 times worse
so when she was with her ex her common
thing would be to drive around the metro
area that I live in for an hour to two
hours till she was able to calm down and
sleep that was her
anxiety coping mechanism and now it's
it's this
um it's gotten to a really bad point
um so just to give you a parameter it's
been about a thousand dollars in this
calendar year which on games like on
phone games
yes so like if you imagine like um
that's one thousand more dollars than
I've ever spent on a mobile game
wow so I'll I'll look at my credit card
statement and I'll just see
I won't name the developer I don't want
to insult them on your show but I'll
just see like constant work I like items
on here and
I suffer from Financial anxiety uh
having a lack or something like an
overdraft causes me to have a visceral
reaction because I never had that before
I was with my partner I never
overdrafted my checking account
um and I I knew exactly how much money
was in my checking account at all times
so being with my my partner now
she's exactly the opposite and she
spends money
on this on that and it's just um
I I I don't know I I can't get her to
budget I've tried that route
let me let me hop in here let me hop in
here okay so first and foremost cancel
that credit card immediately today
okay okay
um this is going to get out of control
in a wild way and I'd be willing to bet
money maybe wrong if I'd be willing to
bet money no no pun intended here
um that this is not the only thing she's
spending money on
yeah there's no possible way this is the
only thing and this is one of those
moments that people find out like it was
a thousand bucks It Was Eighteen hundred
dollars suddenly it's 25
000 bucks and it's you're talking a
couple of years to recover from it I
would cancel that card today
this is you stopping the bleeding of
somebody you love right in front of you
and they may say ouch this hurts I hate
this get your hands off me I'm not gonna
let you bleed out in front of me
okay that's what that move is all right
backing out
listen to me super clear and super
careful okay
all anxiety is is an alarm system for
your body period
it is not a driver of behavior it
doesn't make you do things you don't
want to do
it doesn't force you into other
behaviors XYZ they fill in the blank
I'll even go one step further
she chose to remain in that relationship
with that guy and not to undermine
abusive relationships man I've sat with
people forever in the in those
situations they're brutal and ugly
that guy didn't set didn't make her
anxiety worse
her body was screaming at her to get out
of this situation and she stayed
and it got louder and it got louder and
it got louder
and so I don't want to demonize anxiety
I don't want to live in a house without
a smoke detector that's insane right
what I want to do is begin to ask what
about this life what about this
ecosystem that this body lives in that
this person lives in your wife or your
your friend or whoever or you
what is it about this ecosystem that my
body keeps telling me we're not safe
we're not safe we're not safe we're not
safe
because most people spend all their time
trying to shut the alarm off instead of
dealing with the fire
okay so number two
and any sort of diagnosis is a context
not an excuse
I had was diagnosed at one point with
OCD I had anxiety all those things fine
I still had to show up at work
and I get distracted counting things and
I have to check my locks a bunch okay
great that means I gotta get up 15
minutes earlier
or five minutes earlier or two minutes
earlier
that means I have to be really really
particular about how I exercise how I
reach out to friends and Community how I
take care of my body et cetera and by
the way like I don't make any laps
around my house much anymore
it's gone
so to say like I have to do this because
it's completely opposite in fact it
strengthens it number three here's the
gnarly thing about anxiety
in her case something is setting that
trigger off and I have a feeling I know
what it is and you're not gonna like it
but I'll tell you in just a second
it sets that alarm off to which she
immediately runs to a numbing
um a numbing Behavior well that's
driving around for two hours listening
to sad songs listening to Olivia
Rodriguez and singing and singing or it
is her sitting in a bathroom with the
door locked on video games on her phone
whatever it is it's a numbing Behavior
here's the problem her brain won
her brain sounded an alarm for her to
avoid a situation that it just deemed a
threat whether that's loneliness whether
that's a scary romantic partner whether
that's any number of things Financial
stress whatever it is
and when she goes to a numbing Behavior
the body goes ah we avoided it and it
puts a GPS pin in that move this one
works do it louder next time
and so the only way to heal from anxiety
the only way to deal with those alarms
is to run directly towards them
that's it
and I don't mean that in some woo-woo
fluffy way I mean directly at them
like so in your case
why am I so why does my body try to get
my attention every time there's a dollar
missing in my account
the reason I had Financial anxiety if
you will that's not even a diagnostic
but I get stressed out money was so
contentious we didn't have any growing
up it was scary and it also my dad was a
policeman and my community didn't pay
him enough to give us groceries
and I remember resenting that but it was
all wound up in that and so I went and
borrowed six figures worth of student
loans and cars and houses and all this
crap so that I could not be that and I
ended up in a bigger hole than my old
man ever was in
and so my body was letting me know
you're not saying if you're not safe
You're Not Safe You're Not Safe you see
what I'm saying so anxiety is not the
bad guy here this world is
now when you say you have anxiety
anxiousness what often happens when
somebody is their body is responding
anxiously
they partner up with another anxious
person
and that electricity feeds that
electricity which feeds that electricity
and suddenly you get two radioactive
people sharing a bed together and it's
combustible
so are you an anxious guy too or a very
particular guy or a very I don't say OCD
in the clinical sense but a very
everything's gonna be an order kind of
guy
I'm very analytical yeah
analytical what a positive spin well
done
um how long has she struggled with this
anxiety
um for about
five years now which should be about the
time she was with the ACT I would be
willing to bet my car it's not a nice
one that it's been going on way longer
than that
yeah if she traced it back to when she
was a kid
he was adopted she was adopted and she
doesn't
her
birth mom is not um
there in the head
um would probably be the two sheets to
the win would probably be a good way of
describing her mother's mental acuity
she's not yeah she's struggling what
about her anyway we can go down that
road we don't have to do that right now
um
I'll give you the line that snapped me
out of it
here is a direct quote from my wife
this is about 12 years ago now
she said in a very quiet calm manner
I am watching the man I love die
and I can't sit here and watch that
will you please go talk to somebody
and my numbing behaviors Joe were work
my numbing behaviors were
um
uh reading Journal articles
and creating these big Maps so I could
figure out how people worked
my numbing things were watching stand-up
comedians and like I had notebooks where
I was charting out which jokes were
funny and how long they took between
jobs it was insane
everybody's got different numbing things
but my wife sat down and said I'm
watching you die and I love you too much
and it was that moment that I finally
felt somebody loved me so much that they
weren't interested in what I was in all
this peripheral stuff they were just
watching me drown
and it I burned them every time they
reached into help
so I went and got help
yeah I don't think that's a lot of it it
is but you trying to solve the Alarm
Systems will not work they will just
reinforce them because her body will
tell her hey he doesn't see the threat
let's ring the sucker even louder he
can't hear these things
and every time you go to the periphery
and say hey you need to stop doing this
she's going to move to another either
her body's gonna accept that as
rejection
which is a Cornerstone of an anxious
body is a lack of connection
um which is weird because you're like
we're married we're right here we sleep
together we sleep in the same bed
but her body is saying not safe not safe
not safe and so the path forward here is
I'm going to provide a safe place for
you and me
in that safe place starts with me
telling you I love you so much I can't
watch you I can't watch you die I can't
watch you numb your life out you're
worth more than a numbed out life
does that make sense
yeah
is that ringing is any of this ringing
true to your home
yeah I I mean I I hope she never dies
off of mobile apps and her anxiety I
just
it's not
about the mobile apps
because I promise you I promise you you
know this
you're married to a taser
yeah
and this is just one of 15 different
numbing things but I'll tell you it
escalates and it moves and it goes from
mobile apps to
um
some guy who really thinks she's cute
and funny at work
who sends one funny emoji that she
responds to with one funny emoji it goes
to
one more drink
it goes to I'm just gonna go to bed
early
yeah
I've just done this for too long
it's not about the mobile apps
it's about watching your wife feel like
she has to hide from her own life
because she can't handle how intense it
is and it feels like I gotta run away
from that intensity and the only way to
heal is to run directly into it most of
us can't do that by ourselves
you gotta call a professional get some
help you gotta go see a counselor and
say I'm tired of being this exhausted
my husband told me he loves me so much
and he's watching me slowly drain out of
my own life I don't want to stop that
I'm gonna send you both I'm gonna send
you a copy of building a non-anxious
life and I want you all to go through
that book together
I'll give you a road map or at least
give y'all some questions to ask
yourself inside your own home
to begin to say okay why are these
alarms ringing all the time in here
and you my friend need to ask those
questions too because I think they're
reading off in your life too you've just
chosen to to try to handle them by being
very analytical
I've tried to handle them by ignoring
them both strategies are pathological to
their extremes
but I want y'all to read this book
together and start looking at each one
of these pieces and if you get to a
piece you can't dig into that's when you
call a counselor and say I need some
help here
I've got high hopes for your marriage
because mine is is as good as they come
and
I had a partner that stuck with me
she kept calling me out and kept saying
I miss you where are you where are you
and then I went did the work
y'all can too I promise we'll be right
back
what's up friends Dr John deloney here
and I want to let you in on a secret
that most people didn't tell you before
you got married honesty and intimacy
take practice they don't just happen you
gotta put the Reps in in a beautiful
weekend away in Nashville Tennessee is a
great way to do just that so join me in
Rachel Cruz right here at the Ramsey
Event Center for a money and marriage
getaway you'll learn how to have healthy
conversations around money boundaries
and even sex and Intimacy in your
marriage plus we're gonna have an
incredible great time this weekend is
for couples in every season of life and
engaged couples are welcome too but it's
coming up fast October 19th through the
21st it's a three-day Retreat the cost
is 799 bucks but you can take a hundred
dollars off when you use the code deloni
at checkout that's three Incredible Days
for you and your spouse for just 699
bucks go to ramsesolutions.com get way
today that's
ramseysolutions.com getaway
all right we're back let's go out to
Kailyn in Columbus Ohio what's up Kaelyn
Hi how are you doing great how about you
um okay
uh what's up how can I help
um and you told me I could call back
whenever and kind of tell you what's
going on and oh no did I give you did I
give you bad advice
okay all right cool well so what's up
yeah
so my question is how can I support my
spouse in the aftermath of my Mental
Health crisis
give me some more contacts what happened
oh
um so
almost three weeks ago so like just a
couple days after I talked to you last
time
um I was admitted to a psychiatric
crisis stabilization Hospital on an
in-law I'm sorry 72 hour hold
on oh man that means you were acutely
suicidal what happened
I yeah I just didn't want to be alive
anymore yeah
um
they I'd been depressed for a while this
summer and so my doctor increased the
medication I was on and I think it was
the wrong medication for my body because
a week after the medication everything
just got like 100 times worse and it
just felt like I was gonna hold it I
could never crawl out of
so I went to the hospital I've actually
heard I've actually heard it the other
way
um where
when they ratchet up your meds a lot
in an acute setting
it actually takes somebody who's in a
black hole and gives them just enough
gumption to cash out
yeah
you see what I'm saying
instead of pulling it deeper down the
rabbit hole it actually pulls you up
where you can see just a little bit I
can just reach to the top of the counter
to go ahead and get off this train
yeah
so things are bad yeah let's back out
why did you call the show originally
the first one
um
about my mom asking me
okay and feeling like resentful towards
her so yeah it's not really they're
actually related to that well but I mean
I'm just trying to get a context for
your depression but that's not really
what you're calling so let's get let's
get to yeah the call so number one I'm
so
so glad that you're alive
thank you are you
most of the time
okay I'll take that as a win right now
yeah
um
um do you I know when you're sitting in
the black hole and you feel tired
and you feel like I'm out
do you also feel like people would be
better off without you around
yeah I'm gonna yeah and I have like more
contact for that okay tell me more about
that
um so
especially after coming home
like crazy
um when I was in the hospital my mom
wanted to see me and I didn't want to
see her just because like she's causing
so much stress
um
so my husband had to kind of relay that
information
and it didn't go over very well my mom
basically filled my whole family that my
husband is abusive and manipulative and
keeping me from her
and so like no one is talking to my
husband and it's like I just feel so
horrible because I like created this
mess
I'm gonna challenge that hard is that
cool
yeah okay you play no role in this
your husband did exactly what he was
supposed to do which is stand between
you and any sort of danger coming your
way
yeah and that was your mom
God bless your husband dude good for him
he stood down a dragon and that Dragon
couldn't do anything to him because he's
a strong man and he loves you so she
went and burned down everything else in
the neighborhood
yeah all of your safety nets all your
relationships all the people you reach
out to his reputation all of it that is
not you Galen
you're separate from that in fact
she's been trying to drag you underwater
with her for years
yeah and you've kept fighting
because that's who you are you're so
strong and you don't even see it
and then you married an amazing guy who
will stand shoulder to shoulder with you
and say let's do this together
yeah right
yeah
so I want you to hear I know how you
feel
I trust you and you tell me how you feel
I'm asking you to trust me when I tell
you how you feel is not reality
reality is you're a very strong woman
who
um is a core part of your husband's life
or he wouldn't stand in front of the
fire for you
and vice versa right
so when it feels heavy and dark
challenge that feeling because it's not
true
I'm heartbroken that your mom treats you
like this and treats him like this
it's truly heartbreaking
yeah so I called my mom
um last week or the week before
um and basically told her like this is
not my husband this is
um and I hadn't had like a conversation
with her like this so I I don't know but
I just said like right now you are
causing me anxiety being around you
makes me stressed out because I'm just
so worried about your financial
situation all the time and I need to
focus on getting better and healing
right now and so I need space from you
and it seemed to go okay but she keeps
like messaging my husband like I'm so
sad when can I see Kaylin again okay but
listen this I want to give you some
context this is bigger than money
yeah your mom has used you for your
entire life to prop her up whether that
was emotional psychological Financial
and now she's trying to use you again to
make her feel better because you're in
the hospital
yeah that's insane
your job in your lowest moments when
you're hurting when you're surrounded by
Medical Care Professionals your job is
not to make her feel better
she's a grown woman that's her job in
her community that she should have
surrounding her
but she's used you as a life raft and
that was never your job you're her
daughter
can I just tell you how
out of this world proud of you I am for
having that conversation with her
thank you
like that's a that's not a little win
so after you get out of this out of of
an involuntary hold here's the goal
little wins
yeah right I want you just to shower
today and you can get back in bed if you
all had those conversations I just want
you have one meal and you get back in
bed have y'all walked through that
yeah okay and I'm actually back at work
now excellent actually yeah
but a big win is
you calling the dragon and saying hey
you are a prop part of this problem here
and I am going I value my
health and my body and my personality
and my marriage so much that I am
building a wall between us
dude that is that takes a long time for
someone to get the strength and courage
to do that I I can't tell you how proud
of you I am for that it's amazing
can you do me a favor
yeah wherever you're sitting will you
stand up like real tall don't get up
just like put your back straight and I
want you to like take your shoulders and
clinch them up real tight around your
ears just do it for like two seconds one
two and then drop them
like
you did that
like for real
yeah
and I know it hurt and you hung up the
phone and probably felt guilty and
patted oh my gosh what's gonna happen
I'm so proud of you okay so we're now
we're back and now my guess is your
husband
is hovering over you like a umbrella
like an Ella Ella umbrella yes and I
know it's because he loves me and he's
worried but it's like just constant you
know like he's just so panicked that I'm
gonna do something stupid and I get it
but are you going to it feels like a lot
I don't think so nope that's not a good
answer
okay no okay
are you saying that just to shut me up
no okay
if there's any any crack in that
concrete he's going to do what he can to
cover it up
as he should
yeah as any of us who love our wives
would do
what you'll have to work through right
now is the the development of a plan
that is Ironclad that you will stick to
and that he will stick to and that your
medical professionals will stick to what
does that mean
I need you can text me four times a day
all these texts are stressing me out
but I also know that you love me and I
love you and I need that connection so
we're gonna agree to text four times a
day
we're gonna agree to SOS get on skin
contact four times a day right when we
wake up we're gonna stay in bed an extra
two minutes and just hold hands and
touch feet
yeah I'm gonna see what I'm saying like
we're gonna come up with a plan and
we're gonna you especially Caitlin are
gonna stick to that plan Like Glue
okay and that's going to slowly
slowly
release his grip on
okay she's safe
she's safe
the woman who I pledged my whole life to
is safe
now I can breathe too
yeah
right does it make you uncomfortable
that he loves you that much
no okay
when you're in the black hole though
you feel like
his life would be better if you were
gone didn't you
yeah why is that
okay that's okay
um
I don't know I feel like
I just don't like add anything to anyone
like I don't like
add value to anything
okay
as I said earlier I will I will honor
the fact that that's your feeling
all of the evidence that you've given me
is to the contrary
and it's important to remember this one
thing feelings are not designed to tell
us the truth that's not their job their
job is to keep us safe
and so like when a soccer ball rolls
into the street and my son goes to get
it and I scream you're gonna die
probably not gonna die
but my job is to keep him alive right
not to tell them the truth in that
moment
similarly that's your body's telling you
like hey here's somebody else who love
said they love us the last time somebody
said they loved us
they were a vampire
they try to take everything
and this guy sounds like he's for real
is he for real
so the next time you feel like you don't
add any value
I want you to remember this conversation
and once you remember that guy
who right now you are so annoyed that he
is so close to you all the time because
he loves you that much
yeah
do I have your solemn promise that if
you ever get
um feeling like you want to hurt
yourself again that you'll call somebody
yeah
say I solemnly promise
I found my promise okay you you can't
lie against a podcast or a YouTube show
that's like uh Cosmic or something
okay
okay I think here it like in all honesty
the conversation goes like this with
your husband
um I'm home for two weeks I'm home for
three weeks
I can tell you can't breathe which then
makes me not breathe with which then
makes you not breathe and so yeah this
is our reality
and you look him in the eye and you hold
both of his hands and you say I will
never
hurt myself again
ever
and I want you to say it with conviction
and mean it and if you don't believe
that then you gotta call your
psychiatrist and your counselor right
away you promise
yeah okay
I'm having a hard time believing you
right now
okay well part of it is because
it's hard when people say like
hurt yourself because I don't know if
you mean like self-harm or suicide or
both both
okay
because you have to stop cutting too
I know
that that that that that build up inside
builds up and builds up and builds up
and that's that ultimate fatigue I'm
just done
yeah
you know what I mean
yeah and can you tell I've had this
conversation a whole bunch in my life
yeah
foreign
but you've got to go sit with somebody
and say I want to stop cutting
which in and of itself I doesn't even
get my heart rate up that doesn't bother
me but when you attach that to this idea
that
um I'm slowly kind of sort of ish
practicing
and so if you're going to hurt yourself
or if you're going to take your life
you have to make that call
yeah
everybody's life around using Ash
if you're not here
yeah my counselor keeps telling me
um
like I said like I feel like all of this
mess wouldn't have happened if I just
killed myself and she was like Caitlin
it would just be like a hundred times
worth what are you talking about it
would be infinitely worse
infinitely worse and I don't care about
them right now I care about you
you wouldn't be here
and my children would miss out on the
contribution you're going to add to the
world
I don't want that world
okay
yeah and I know it doesn't feel like you
add a contribution to it that's where
the work is
and so you hear me do you trust me
yeah okay
so you hear me saying what I'm saying
and you don't feel that what I'm saying
registers as truth and I get that
instead of being scared by that say huh
I gotta figure out how to build a bridge
to that
because I trust that guy even when I
don't trust me I trust that guy I trust
my counselor even I don't trust me I
trust my husband even I don't trust me
so how do I build a bridge to get there
and that's what your counselor helps you
do
and it's about learning some new skills
that's it you got a tool kit and all you
have in it is a razor blade
and a bottle of pills right
yeah yes cool let's get some new tools
because the pain you feel is real the
home you grew up in was a chaotic mess
we're gonna get some new tools
we're gonna learn to exercise and you're
like no yup it has to happen
or you can learn to go for a walk with
your husband every day
you're gonna learn to turn Electronics
off and not just spin out and spin out
and spin out and spin out
You're Gonna Learn to have people over
to your house and hang out
there's just skills
they're not crazy things for crazy
people who got talents that you didn't
get just skills
what do you do for a living
I'm a teacher oh my gosh you've learned
that skill
laughs
what grade do you teach
fourth they're the best
and did you know your room of 25 little
fourth graders goes homes to their
parents and every night and tells them
how much they love Miss Kalyn
I think someone do they all do even the
ones they don't like you do
because you know
what some of them are going through in
their homes
yeah and you know that some of them look
in the mirror don't like what they see
and you know what that feels like
you know that some of them sit in that
classroom and wish they could just
disappear in their own seat and they
can't
and that makes you
that makes you the dream dream teacher
I'm good at my job no you are I just
want you to love yourself as much as
those fourth graders love you
at least Fair
yeah fair so you're not leaving me
you're not leaving those kids you're not
leaving your knucklehead husband who
loves you so much
and you've already taken the awesome
first hard step of not leaving but just
separating yourself from
people who hurt you cool
yeah and we're done with cutting
and we're going to find some alternative
behaviors there
okay okay
you got no more reason to punish Kayla
and kailyn's pretty awesome
cool
yeah
so let's make a plan with husband in a
very detailed plan almost like a fourth
grade like like you would give to your
fourth graders at eight o'clock is when
we hug and at 10 15 is when I have a
break and I'll text you say how much I
love you and at noon I will text you and
at this time I'll text you and at dinner
we will do this
and if I
end up cutting in my car out in the
parking lot before school starts my
promise is I will call this counselor
and I will call you
if I start feeling like I don't want to
be here anymore and I'm going to take my
life I will call this person and I will
call this person and I will call you
you have my solemn word promise
and we will begin to take a walk
together before school starts and in the
evening
and we'll get a dog and we'll fill in
the blank but y'all come up with a plan
together so that he can exhale a little
bit which will allow you to Exhale a
little bit which will allow him to
Exhale a little bit and takes all of the
smoke out of your house
just gotta practice it and I honestly
recommend that y'all you and him go to
your counselor and say hey we want to
make a safety plan for our home so that
we can all breathe in here
and your Council will probably smile
real big and too I got you on that one
so so grateful you're here Kayla you
again call anytime call next week we'll
have you back on
so glad that you're here
[Music]
I'll be right back
hey Dr John deloney here I'm super
jazzed to announce my new book building
a non-anxious life is now available for
pre-order listen we all experience some
level of anxiety or stress or burnout
every day but most of us don't know how
to recognize it let alone deal with it
and here's the good news anxiety doesn't
have the last word I know this because
I've sat with thousands of you and I
know this because I've been there too
if you create a life of intentionally
living out the six daily choices I've
outlined in this book you'll be able to
better respond at whatever life throws
at you this book will help you learn
practical steps to overcome anxiety plus
when you pre-order the book now I'm
gonna give you something to help you
today that's why you'll instantly get my
newest talk smoke fire and freedom where
I break down the misunderstandings and
myths we believe about anxiety how to
reclaim your freedom and how to build a
non-anxious life so pre-order building a
non-anxious life today for just 20 bucks
at John deloney.com
all right we're back as we wrap up
today's show we have we're going back to
the new segment am I the problem yes so
we got our uh we got another one in
first of all people we need your emails
in the subject line or right in the
beginning type in am I the problem send
us your questions keep them fairly short
so we have time to do them this person
asked am I the jerk am I the jerk
however you want to phrase it fine with
me and then also make sure comment when
we read this we want to hear your
comments if you think this person's the
problem so comment
um here you know in the comments or on
the reviews that would be great all
right you ready let's do it we moved
into our house a little over a year ago
and our next door neighbor closed on
their house a week later and immediately
poured concrete starting at 5am even
before getting the okay from the HOA
she said she told the contractors not to
start before the required 7 A.M but was
not there to supervise we were just
getting over coveted and my infant
daughter was awoken at the early hour of
5 30 A.M
I did post on a mom's group that I was
looking for advice on how to approach my
neighbor and I did mention that I hated
them
although I hated the act more than them
but the exhausted State I was in I was
mad the daughter their daughter who does
not live with them saw the post and
recognized me when I went to go talk to
the neighbor
ever since we've had a contentious
relationship with these neighbors they
did install a fence without talking to
us and expect us to pay half of it even
though I found a better contractor with
a better price
I've tried to approach her on a couple
of times about sharing the reasonable
cost but she will not even talk to me at
all am I the jerk
yes
disagree and feel free to disagree with
me I think I think said no it's yes and
no it's yes on
you know the stress of moving everybody
knows the stress of moving and probably
as a part of the stress of moving there
was some sort of built-in we have to do
this to this property right away we've
got dog chickens whatever gotta get a
fence up
and
um I was almost late to work yesterday I
have a huge long long long driveway like
more than a quarter mile driveway that
goes back into the woods and some
painters from somebody else's Barn
they're redoing their Barn down down the
down the holler from where I live they
drove up there's only one way in so I
got all the way to the bottom I had to
back my car all the way up this hill
anyway
they made a mistake they were just
contractors getting to a job and want to
get this thing done because they booked
too many jobs that's fine
where I think she was wrong where she
was the jerk was she didn't just go
knock on the neighbor's door and say
or number one didn't just go this is a
one-time thing dude they showed up at
5am they're not gonna pour concrete
every weekend if it was like a dance
party then yeah but ah dude that's
annoying I'm gonna go about my day
that's annoying they woke my daughter up
and we were getting over coveted
whatever happened
she went to the moms group on Facebook
where happiness and joy goes to die
just it's where courtesy and kindness
and rational thinking Goes Up in Flames
and then so she created I think this
relational like bam and then it's really
hard to come back
and now her neighbors being unreasonable
and moronic I personally wouldn't pay
for that fence I just wouldn't and until
we sat down to have a conversation about
it I'm not gonna pay for the fence
because you wouldn't just built a thing
you can't just charge me five thousand
dollars for a thing that I didn't even
ask for it and yeah you know what I'm
saying so no we're gonna have that so
she's being a retaliatory jerk
but I think it started with
I hate her and come on man they need a
reset it's like she needs to just go
over there and say listen this started
off horribly and that's my fault I
screwed up sorry yes can we just start
over with a gift basket yeah and then if
they don't then you know there's not
much you can do about it but just kind
of humble yourself go over there and be
like I'm so sorry or as the great Taylor
Swift says I'm the problem it's me let's
start with that and like a gift basket
and uh I'm so sorry can we control all
delete this thing
and then if they go no we hate you well
then you've been the bigger person right
then you've got jerky neighbors you've
got jerky neighbors and then you've got
some choices to make which is awful if
you just bought this house you're an
infant and you're trying to oh bad
neighbors are just the worst the worst
just stop the worst but also if I had
just moved into a house and I finally
was able to coordinate the closing date
and the concrete guys and the fence guys
and they went too early and somebody's
already bombing me on the neighborhood
Facebook page telling me they hate me
what I would think oh great I just moved
in with terrible neighbors with no Grace
and no flexibility no understanding for
how complex all this is so I think you
started it
and when you start it the only way this
thing gets different is if you just take
a different track
and if you want to I can just imagine
hey uh can we talk about this fence no
you hate me remember you posted on the
mom's Facebook page and stop having
Facebook pages
go talk to your neighbors drive me crazy
is that fair I'm 100 Joe what do you
think
oh yeah yeah definitely for civility
we're in the neighborhood we call him
neutral Joe
we call him Swiss Joe he's like whatever
you just said man that sounds great
sounds cool all right hey
if you have a problem with your neighbor
just get all uncomfortable and anxious
and nervous about it and then
let's go talk to him
go talk to him
give them an opportunity to not show up
and in so doing you give them an
opportunity to go oh my gosh I'm a
person too I'd love to help
thank you for being with us today
stands cool don't do drugs all that
stuff
be nice to your neighbors get off the
Facebook pages we'll see you soon
please